[Music]
I've escaped a Vietnam and promised one
of the best cooks in the country that
I'll get to grips with this unique
cuisine in just a week I'm hotfooting it
out of Ho Chi Minh City and flying 1500
kilometers north to the capital Hanoi
it's a huge learning curve for me it'd
be very ignorant from a chef's point of
view not to embrace their understanding
of they waste nothing
and eat everything Hanoi is a communist
stronghold traditionally this part of
the country has a no waste culture our
experts had nose-to-tail eating and won
the tourist female chef has made a
reputation cooking just one ingredient
now this lady's a bit of a hard-ass bit
of a legend I'm in Hanoi for two days
and I'm here for inspiration I'm gonna
get him there see she's up to
and hopefully yeah like a magpie steal
some ideas what she's doing Jesus
where's the boss hello how are you
Jordan I'm Benna the old entity luckily
for me a local restaurant owner has come
to my rescue
Wow madam quack Wow aah Oh I said quack
the duck and you are mine my name's
Trace call me Kwan yes the rice and mrs.
duck yeah so where's mr. Peking I don't
want to piss her off
yeah I will keep on a good side all
right yeah I heard she has a ferocious
temper say all right three cleavers by
the side of how many ducks a day does
yourself ladies is the name to play see
GU about a hundred ducks of days that's
why her name is Douglas how many
husbands are secured mrs. duck I spent
30 years perfecting her menu but before
I get to taste it she wants me to meet
her key ingredient out back about ten
days ten days old ahold of these
formants or find that first in order to
find the plumpest bird mrs. duck has
devised a unique test can you hear this
out yeah Rama duck to the breath yeah
but I'm fine never touch just listen
just let us down so she's wait she's
listening for a waited yeah heavy sound
can't believe I'm doing this for them
okay there's a lot of media that sounds
good I'm beginning to think Missy's duck
is Quackers butter dishes famous
throughout Hanoi so she must be doing
something right so this is how she
prepares the duck every day yes and it's
important to bleed the ducks otherwise
it's gonna spoil the texture than me I
get that but why should cutting you
there we go here it's just stay away
from the stormer and may get the bad
food summer storm up into the plant yes
yeah she believes in slaughtering them
just before she started cooking up so
it's done that fresh does it always like
that a lot sir and then cooking so start
off with a net yes yeah what's the labor
look just never get bored plucking ducks
that's beautiful everything oh really
yeah houses and everything about the
duck is nearly the goddess of the house
duckies the goddess of the house very
quick gone anything to keep her happy
now the dirty work is over mrs. duck
wants to give me a lesson and
nose-to-tail butchery straight down the
middle
pass the cleaver to her she want to
teach you how to shoot she wants to nap
teach me how to sharpen a knife
Hey oh yeah yeah stay off off yeah Nick
it's amazing I've never actually
slaughtered one in the kitchen
take this feathers off and butchered it
from there is there anything up the duct
that she never uses you see that yep
other plans as they buy all the buy all
very bitter yeah if that purse of the
duck it ruins the texture but no smelly
I'm enjoying myself I'm about to learn
mrs. duck sweet and sour sauce
but all of a sudden she become
tight-lipped okay her life so not easy
to give her life I'm not asking to marry
her I wasn't for the recipe
yes you and I look at me I set up Miss
Easter chilies lemongrass oyster sauce
yeah duck bean curd sugar why are you
being such a hard-ass when I've just
plucked your dog's even her husband
doesn't know about that serious oh my
god you know your one-off she's unique
she's like a fine bottle of wine they
only produced one bottle because it was
another Queen she's amazing huge source
of inspiration more importance she knows
her stuff I mean big time so she hasn't
focused on 25 30 dishes
she's just focused on a unique way with
duck she shows no mercy straight in
there
nothing squeamish about mrs. duck is the
real bit [ __ ] scared to be honest
while her signature dish cooks I'm going
to sample the rest of Missy's dunk menu
so many different ways and different
sort of styles of cooking duck that's
amazing you want to try the Hat if you
want you easier nice and tender
that's good that's very good I'll show
you - it's got a leathery liver texture
to it now for the main event the
barbecued duck is ready just mix with
the marinade and then on top of the
charcoal grill that's great I know the
fan obviously to intensify the heat
that is delicious and she's managed to
use everything even there as a piece of
the legate's it's amazing